okay in this video we're going to show
you how to fix the left knee okay now
the only time this wouldn't work is if
you had an actual cut complete sever of
a tendon or a ligament or a bone break
something beyond the scope but if
there's just pain in the knee what
you're gonna do the way to fix it is you
work on the opposite leg okay so let's
say this hurts right here you're gonna
work on the muscle the quad the this
muscle right here it's called the thigh
muscle quads muscle right here and
there's one that comes straight right
here into the hip and the function of
this muscle is just to kind of bring the
leg out extend the leg okay so now you
can use your hand or you can use the
tool I like a tool because it's it's
easier but the whole thing is you're
gonna take and you're gonna strip out a
strip down this muscle right in the
right down the center of your thigh now
you're probably wondering like how is
this gonna fix this knee well you're
gonna find out when you stand up it's
quite amazing has to do with the
anything on this side of the body is
connected neurologically to the opposite
side so by working on this side you're
actually fixing the brain and you're
improving the stuck flow because pain is
a stuck flow this erases that stuck flow
so your brain doesn't have to just
constantly just send signals down pain
pain pain pain okay so we're going to
come here and we're going to press down
right in the center if we use the device
we'll come down here and just work out
the knots right down the center okay so
if you split your thigh and you come
right in the center but now here's the
key the most important thing is to take
mid thigh and I press it down and slowly
come up
so let's loli come up into the thigh
right in the center and you want to get
all the way up into the muscle close to
your hip so we're going to take this
kind of attachment right through in
there and you're going to just press on
it now you're gonna feel like there's a
cigar-shaped muscle right the touch of
the hip and that's the one that comes
here you want to get right on that
muscle and slowly kind of come down
down onto that hip right through in here
okay now realize that when you find the
opposite muscle on this side it's going
to be very very very painful way more
painful than your actual knee and that's
just the nature of how it works so in
other words you want to use that to know
that you're hitting the right spot so
you can also use I like to use this
because it's a little more powerful we
can come and just kind of just press
down into that hip there and just work
that out all those knots all the way down
here okay so you're gonna work that for
like one to two minutes and then you're
gonna move your knee and you're gonna
like well huh
that feels better but now we're not done
there's another muscle that's slightly
to the right of that it's kind of like
right at the angle we want to work on
that one so this muscle this is part of
the quads we can come up or down but we
want to come right down here and work
you can use your hands if you want the
thumbs if you have strong thumbs and we
come right in there and we're going to
just scroll right down that muscle very
important to get that the hip muscle
right through and here yeah you just
want to make sure that this is on it is
so we come and we we get now you see
we're not right in the center we're over
about an inch to the right this is very
important to get to this hip and again
you can use this right here and work out
that muscle the name of this muscle is
called the vastus lateralis because
lateral means on the outside and that's
this means like vast it's a bigger
muscle because it spans all through here
so that's a little Latin for you so
we're going to come right in here and
you're going to find that you're trying
to find the tender spots to the absent
knee and you come right in there and you
work that out and of course it's not
easy to press on something that hurts
but the more you work this out the more
this knee starts to pain goes away okay
we come in there we just work this out
again I'm inching down this muscle right
through here until I strip all that down
okay and the last thing we want to do
there's
a little muscle on the outside of this
leg right here and there's actually a
kind of a sheath of tendon that comes
from here and there's a little muscle
right here so that's the third thing
we're going to do we're going to work on
the side sometimes people can lay on the
side of their body and have a foam
roller do this which I'll demonstrate in
a bit but this is the one that I like to
do we've just come and you can use your
hands too but we're working on the side
right through here of your leg all the
way down this one is very painful and a
lot of people so we're working on this
side here and all the way up into that
hip right in there
this is the one that will be a little
bit on the painful side right through
here okay and then right into that hip
so you're gonna work on all these spots
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take my pin out of my pocket and I'm
going to demonstrate how I'd roll on
this thing right here so this is a
little bit different because you want to
just come right here and kind of roll
your leg on the side right through here
and want to come right up into that hip
again you're on your side you'll be on
your bed and just work that out just so
your leg is really working this point
and then up into the hip right to here
again this is all for this left knee
right through and here working out for a
couple of minutes and then my hip bones
right here I have to go over the hip
bone and then come on the other side of
it the most improvement for your left
knee is going to be this area right
through in here okay so that's all you
do for the knee and if it does not work
over and doesn't improve
you'll be doing this once you know once
or twice a day for like a week if it
doesn't seem to stabilize it go get a
scan and double-check to make sure
there's not a tear in your knee because
no matter what you do if there's a tear
it's not going to get better